hello and welcome to the movieclips 2014
year in preview or we don't just talk
about movies that excite us but news
stories potential trailers all the kind
of big movie related things that are
going to excite us in 2014 so let's get
started 2014 has some huge movies for
the comic book audience not necessarily
comic book adaptations but for everybody
who loves that kind of stuff else we got
transformers age of extinction Michael
Bay brings us the fourth Transformers
movie this time shy is out I think megan
fox is out but we got mark wahlberg and
we haven't seen that much we haven't
seen a trailer yet for age of extinction
we've seen some posters of some stills
but we know it's going to be amazing
attached to michael bay's named ninja
turtles they're coming yeah this is
director I think it's jonathan liebesman
we still don't know what the ninja
turtles will be no Megan Fox does wear a
yellow jacket sort of like the cartoon I
mean sort of like it's not really gonna
even be close to that I bet a little bit
I mean she's playing a pro Neil we know
they're splinter and shredder however
it's a white guy playing shredder so I
don't know if that's gonna be that good
so I'm sure they don't have a fence this
way it's really it's really iffy we
again we haven't seen the turtles we
know that they're not from its not from
ooze their alien turtles which kind of
rubbed a lot of fans the wrong way but
we'll see I mean they've been off the
big screen in a live action movie almost
20 years this year we also see Marvel
phase 2 continuing captain america
Winter Soldier so yeah this movie's
gonna be awesome because the winter
soldier is the villain who is actually
Bucky Barnes who fell off a train and
then frozen ice in the first movie and
now he comes back he's been my
brainwashed by the Soviets to be an
assassin and it just looks amazing that
I thought the trailer was great the
Russo brothers are directing I think
it's gonna be a great movie big action
blockbuster we have edge of tomorrow
which stars Tom Cruise now it's cool
this was directed by Doug Liman who for
me is a little hit or miss but the
trailer is cool Tom Cruise again say
what you will about the guy he chooses
quality entertainment to be involved in
I think that this could be a really fun
kind of big action movie um speaking of
big action and fun 22 jump street yeah i
love the first 21 Jump Street I think
he'll so talented to bring like there
are so many great references like
spoiled lurk they bring in Johnny Depp
for the first one and it just is a great
shootout moment yeah and jonah hill and
channing tatum they've had branched out
and they've tried so many different
things yes for sure um but I mean comedy
is one of both of their strong suits so
to see them coming back for the sequel
of a very successful film it's gonna be
a good stuff I'm really excited about
this one dawn of the Planet of the Apes
now to me this has everything going for
it from what we saw in the trailer of
this movie not only have they kind of
gotten rid of the original cast it's
this takes place five years later where
the world has kind of been destroyed
that trailer things got real you know
when Caesar basically gets them all to
rise up together in unison at the end
you know it's a very chilling moment for
all used subscribers of the auteur
theory out there we have some big-name
directors with exciting adaptations this
year not least of which is David Fincher
directing gone girl yeah we started to
read the book yet I did I started to
read the book and was not a huge fan but
a lot of people were a huge fan of it
and whether whether the book is good or
not David Fincher's attached to it i
mean that's another amazing director he
really he really is the stars Ben
Affleck Rosamund Pike they released one
image from this movie so far and it
could not look any more like a David
Fincher film from one picture yeah
another huge artistic director that is
bringing a movie that he's been trying
to get made for almost ten years now to
the screen darren aronofsky finally
making noah or make it releasing noah
the trailer was a little cookie cutter
for me but aronofsky i mean every time
he does anything on a big scale like the
fountain it's pretty it's always unique
whether you think like it or not um and
the cast i mean russell crowe jennifer
connelly emma watson Logan I mean it's
it's an amazing line-up of people
involved in this film so next up we have
kids movies a the lego movie which has
not only lego batman lego ninja turtles
like a Wonder Woman Lego a Chris Pratt
Lego
um aliens like a robot I mean I played
with Legos for people waiting to see
every franchise put together a movie
yeah which I guess they can do because
Lego has licensed these characters I
think that's how they're allowed to put
all of them in and has this great stop
motion animation look but I'm pretty
sure it was only like half stop motion
and a half CGI yeah the line is still
pretty blurry to me too yeah yeah it
looks amazing in the trailer was
hilarious yeah the trailer was
definitely funny um we also have I'm
personally very excited for this film
how to train your dragon 2 yeah I've
been waiting for the sequel for a long
time I think the first one is amazing
it's one of my favorite animated films
ever made and they have the same
creative team back and they've had years
to work on the script and work out the
story they're making this and a third
one so I personally could not be more
excited yeah me too i loved i love take
up as a character i love the Dragons a
toothless and everyone it just Vikings
and Dragons at such a cool animation and
also to be noted the music in the
original Heather train your dragon
Michael all scorers in credit it's
unbelievable is nominated for an Oscar
which is pretty like I mean for not
Pixar movie an animated non pixar
animated movies is quite a feat so
that's really cool we also have
Maleficent which is Disney moving more
in there reimagining kind of like the
Alice in Wonderland live action and
there was also the wants a swath was the
snowing the huntsman kind of live action
these fairy tales with intense amounts
of visual effects and CGI but also a
little bit edgy and i think that the
trailer definitely shows angelina jolie
could be kind of like she could be good
or bad I think the trailer was very up
like so she's probably on the fence yeah
yeah I'm some more book adaptations that
are coming out yeah we have the hunger
games mockingjay part 1 and there's
gonna be a year apart unfortunately I
really wish there was like only like two
months different people who are fans of
these books you know they want to see as
much detail in these movies as they
possibly can they want to see as
complete an annotation as possible so I
understand the move I think it's a smart
move and catching fire was awesome yeah
so I mean if there's to mockingjays I'm
totally for it another one that's coming
out is divergent am ashaming
shailene woodley also kate winslet's in
it yeah which is rate actresses yeah
yeah really really good cast and also I
mean I wasn't a huge fan of the trailer
but I'm a huge fan of the cast and neil
burger directed it he made the
illusionist and limitless he's a really
talented filmmaker and speaking about
taking one book and then making it into
several movies will finally see the end
of The Hobbit witness there and back
again yeah i thought the desolation of
smaug was a step up actually go to the
series and it actually ended sooner than
I thought it would which bodes well for
there and back again me some more action
for that yeah it certainly keep ending
these movies kind of in the middle of
scenes yeah um so which could be
frustrating considering they put them a
year apart well everyone's been talking
about 2015 because I mean there's all of
these anticipated titles that are coming
out then um that affects us and
everything works yeah I'm 2014 we're
gonna see trailers for Avengers 2 we
hope we hope or a teaser or maybe a
poster same with Batman vs Superman
maybe Justice League Jurassic world yeah
Jurassic world and even if we don't see
trailers for these things there's so
many news stories and developments that
we can look forward to for instance we
can finally we'll probably get a plot
synopsis on Jurassic world or more of a
complete plot synopsis start eventually
Star Wars going to start shooting and
we're gonna be at non-stop flow of news
about that a fasting has some characters
for Star Wars hopefully hopefully a plot
synopsis as well um a few other things
that I'm excited about Disney got the
rights to Indiana Jones so we're gonna
see if they're gonna make a move on that
any time soon hopefully not with Shia
LaBeouf I mean if they want to make a
move with Harrison Ford they better
hurry up so 2014 is gonna be pretty cool
guys yeah thank you for watching our
year in per view check out our five
movies that we are the most excited
about out of all the movies that we that
we talked about and thought about in
2014 those are the ones that were most
excited about so click to watch that and
comment below what are you most excited
about the 2014 what do you think Star
Wars is gonna be about hopefully we find
out till next time I'm Ryan I'm Jes
David thank you for watching
member